henrik stenson winner of the Open
Championship the first male Swedish
major championship and did it in
dramatic fashion remarkable fashion and
henrik stenson kind enough to join us
where are you today henrik I'm actually
in sunny Copenhagen we have a little
boats and we took the boat over from
south of Sweden and gonna go for some
dinner when I'm done talking to you
do you have the Claret Jug with you
actually it's at home I'm bringing it on
this trip it's gonna be with me a lot in
the next 12 months but he didn't make
the cut for this one has it sunk union
yeah it's kind of get gets better and
better the more I think about it it was
quite an achievement and a childhood
dream really to to be a major champion
and had a great battle would fail over
the last two days and really really
happy to come out on top you get into a
zone as a golfer athletes talk about
getting into a zone it it it felt like
you were in something on that that final
day when you shoot a 63 did you feel
like it was one of those places where
you're not sure how long you're gonna
stay in it but you're in a different
place towards the end for sure I'm
normally pretty aware I'm you know my
score and everything that's going on but
those last five holes it was one shot at
a time and I didn't know what I made a
part on the loss you know if I shot 63
or 64 65 score was kind of out of the
question at that point I knew I had to
turn 4-under or somewhere around there
and then then it was just so much focus
on each shot so yeah I was definitely
sewn in towards dead
you didn't have to look at the
scoreboard because scoreboard was
playing with you how did that does that
help in any way or you know the fact
that you're going head-to-head with Phil
so you can see what he's doing in real
time yeah I think it makes it since I
was on that with match play in general
YouTube you have to beat your opponent
that's pretty for the simple to see what
you need to do when
joke they tormented normally there's
quite a few guys up there on the
leaderboard and some were playing maybe
behind you so I'm not playing in front
of you so it's definitely easy to see
what you need to do and I think we just
triggered each other to seclude to play
some of our best golf I mean we were
trading blows all the way around for two
days more or less making birdies and
eagles and not too many bogeys so that
was a great match what can you talk
about during room what did you and Phil
talk about well I told him the last day
when he birdie the first time Bowl get
it he's got the lead back and then I
made three birdies in a row and we made
a Eagle on the fourth and I said walking
through the 50 I said I think we've got
a pretty good better ball going here and
you know you're just I've known quite a
quite a few years we've played against
each other in the Ryder Cup we've been
drawn together a lot especially this
year so it's just you know you talk
about everything really not too much
towards the end or when everyone's
really into the game and are you trying
to try to finish the job but he's a good
guy he's a great competitor and it made
it even even bigger for me to beat him
down the stretch like it did because
he's a fantastic player and has been so
for so good two decades you've been
close before why at age 40 did it happen
oh you got tired of waiting in a way I
guess you you're on credit as well if
you've been in in situations wait inside
and I wasn't running away you kind of
always learn something and I'm known
it's always been about putting yourself
in position and this time I was in
position and I felt like like it was my
turn I believed in myself possibly a bit
more than I've done in the past and in
similar situations and and I went out
and played some great golf so yeah it's
hard to tell the difference one thing I
lost lost a friend on that one today
before the tournament sodden and I
really wanted to try and play my best
for him as well and and
certain I did so you know that that was
certainly a 1/1 factor as well so that
wasn't a distraction that was something
that actually you know helped you
motivated you it certainly motivated me
it was some of our common friends as
well that they you know go win this one
for Mike and I thought yeah like why
should and I'll give it my best and yeah
I think that helped my attitude for sure
that week and it was it was a special
special experience parties and you know
because of that as well henrik stenson
the Open champ joining us Dan Patrick
show when when you look at a an event
like that we don't we normally get to
see these us courses but can you put it
into words
what what playing there is like playing
Open Championship golf as opposed to
what we would play here in the States
yeah playing links it's a different game
I guess the easiest way of describe it
is you've got the in tennis you've got
Wimbledon on grass and you got the
French Open on clay so it's a different
surface you normally have strong winds
we had quite a few few breezy days this
year as well and UK the ball a bit lower
there's so many different ways to play
shots as well you can still lift it in
if you want to but a lot of times it's
and you can hit along the ground or even
run it run it up there so there's
different ways to play a play every shot
really and it takes a bit of time to to
get used to it as well and that's why
it's good to get a few rounds in and
both Phil and myself Cato Scottish Open
the week before to get some extra extra
rounds on links golf and we actually did
the same in 2013 when he when he wanted
new form up in a second so I guess I get
that tells you something
how big is golf in Sweden Golf is very
big we the country of up to 10 million
people and I think we got six hundred
golf courses and about 500,000 players
so it's big it's a very popular sport
who would surprise
that you heard from after winning the
open well I've heard from from so many
people and you know getting my name on
that trophy is a very humble experience
some of the Great's that play the game
and and and then get on all the all the
credit for to winning it and from so
many different ways I spoke to our or
princess the other day and the her
husband is a very keen golfer and and
we'd been watching it from wherever they
were at that time and it's been sports
people different you know soccer players
table tennis players Olympic golds in
the past and stuff so I've been getting
congratulations from from all over the
place
okay what is bigger golf or table tennis
in Sweden don't is bigger box and now
without golf as an Olympic sport but
we've had some great table decoration in
the in the past that have challenged the
Chinese and you know it's been it's been
quite extraordinary to watch them do do
well and win Olympic golds for Sweden in
the toss so yeah we're very proud sporty
nation and I'm looking forward going to
Rio and I was rolling on golf is in
there I will see you there
Henrik congratulations enjoy dinner
tonight and thank you for joining us
thank you very much yeah henrik stenson
joining us from a boat and somewhere in
Sweden Denmark was he in Denmark is that
where it was yeah the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience